oh my god email from Jane as you know
I'm on a little gap here in Australia
come and stay anytime you like I'm in
Australia is the sex capital of the
world you know are they call it Down
Under
cuz that's where your face spends most
the time learning it's over the bush
Neil the bush around the per se
she looks well freaked out you think
Emily have anything to do with the car
damn it this is the classic Ozzy shaggin
wagon the mobile version conversion you
know with that pack in there into the
backpack and volley hi come to Byron Bay
it is awesome
we'll be careful must before makes is
actually a crime in Australia yeah a
little starts I don't think they got
boards Katie can't play your song how
about the sound of silence if anyone
starts playing the bongos I'm leaving
sorry for it Simon swear on your Fuji
who are not going to cheat on me just
love you so much
basically I just need to kill myself and
he's gotta be easier than breaking up
with her I just need to Skype oh I've
seen your mum for six months I need to
refresh the image in the wine bank
entire coffee you tip the lid forms
how's that
moving are they right
everyone knows the backpack and girls
are the loosest that's why it's called a
gap here cuz the gap between their legs